más de 48 horas después del alto el
fuego entre gaza e israel el acuerdo
sigue en vigor y parece que la vida ha
vuelto a la normalidad en tel-aviv los
residentes de la mayor ciudad israelí se
apresuran a ir a la playa en lugar de a
los refugios antibombas la situación en
el país está dura es muy compleja no
está claro que sería lo que habría que
hacer y entristece que nada se ha hecho
ni en un sentido ni en otro
nuestro dolor nos hace daño y su dolor
el de los que están al otro lado nos
hace daño la mayoría de israelíes quiere
la paz y quiere algún tipo de contacto
con el otro lado la tranquilidad ha
vuelto a estos cielos en los que tan
solo unos días atrás tronaban cientos de
proyectiles es hora de que la diplomacia
vuelva a la región el secretario de
estado norteamericano es esperado y
probablemente el proceso de paz ocupe un
lugar primordial en su agenda
además yo nunca lo he visto es nuevo no
tengo ni idea de qué es lo que tiene en
mente no puedo decirte que pensará hacer
puesto que no sé nada de él este h yu
dabao lo idea vaya nada va a pasar
volveremos a lo mismo del pasado
mientras en cisjordania se educa a los
niños a odiar a los judíos nunca
tendremos pasos a la bola
las negociaciones de paz es uno de los
pocos asuntos en que israelíes y
palestinos consensual
ambas partes tienen pocas esperanzas en
un proceso que ha estado dormido durante
años